Elizabeth Holmes was sentenced today to
11 and a quarter years in prison this is
her punishment for four counts of
criminal fraud in January a jury found
her guilty of defrauding investors and
theranos the blood testing startup that
she ran
the judge's decision actually falls very
close to what was recommended by a
probation officer who worked up a
independent report which recommended
nine years in prison and the government
recommended 15 years in prison so the
judge was kind of between the two of
them and he was nowhere near what
Elizabeth Holmes wanted which was the
maximum of 18 months the main argument
that we heard from the government were
that Elizabeth Holmes set about to lie
and intentionally defraud people she did
this knowingly it's the question the
community has is
does this work if you believe that it
does I'd like to hear you I know it does
they also talked about how she had never
shown like remorse or taken
responsibility for her crime and in fact
claim that she herself was the victim
the defense in response really played up
Elizabeth's character of her role as a
mother a mother of a toddler and a
pregnant woman who will soon have a
second child
to love Mom Dad
the defense submitted to the judge more
than 140 letters from supporters of
Elizabeth Holmes along with those
letters there were a number of pictures
and in particular Billy Evans who is
Elizabeth Holmes's partner submitted a
four-page photo collage of their family
when Billy Evans submitted these photos
he did redact the face of his young
child to protect his privacy it was
really in an effort to show her as
someone who you'd want as your neighbor
or best friend or someone in your family
and it was quite a humanizing moment for
Elizabeth
the judge did today issue a surrender
date of April 27th of next year so that
means that on April 27th that's her time
to to head to prison